the world is on Pace to have the slowest
economic growth in the past three
decades that according to a new report
by the World Bank global trade this year
is expected to only be half of the
average of preco levels The Slowdown
affects all regions and all countries
growth in advanced economies is set to
slow to a meager
1.2% developing countries are expected
to grow just 3.9 % less than previous
years and while some of it's due to
lingering effects from the co pandemic
there is also more at play inflation
went up interest rates went up to record
levels so financing conditions are much
tighter you have a war in Europe Russian
invasion of Ukraine you have a major
conflict in the Middle East and let's
don't forget about the you know the
climate related natural disasters we are
seeing higher frequency and much larger
cost when the world economy slows it's
often the most vulnerable who suffer the
most the World Bank report says by the
end of this year one out of every four
developing countries will be poorer than
they were before the pandemic one of the
few positives to come out of this report
is the authors predict the risk of a
global recession is now diminishing
primarily because of the strength of the
US economy but overall the report is
somber reading about a world with
slowing economic growth Gabriel zando Al
jaera New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler